hello everyone and welcome to another
tunnel technique class at home I hope
you're all doing fine so today we are
going to work on balance yeah the point
of today's exercises is to make your
legs very strong especially this joint
the uncontroid yeah the ankle joint
together with your core are very
important in holding your balance yeah
now the people who follow this channel
will be already familiar with the
exercises but they were on different
videos so I put them together in this
routine yeah now the exercises are the
same for men and women but if you're a
woman I would recommend that you do
these exercises without high heels yeah
with socks or flats
later if you feel more comfortable then
you can try with high heels yeah and the
only extra thing that you need for these
exercises is a stick yeah but the stick
is optional you can do all the exercises
while holding the stick like this above
your head yeah with straight arms the
advantage of using the stick like this
is that you work on your balance and
also your posture at the same time but
if that's too much then you don't need
to use a stick and you can do the
exercises with your hands on your hips
like this yeah that's up to you okay so
let's start with the one okay one more
feet together straight posture look in
front of you and relax the arms yeah we
start with shoulder rotations remember
we make big circles and slow and we
don't bend the elbows yeah keep the arms
always relaxed okay let's do eight
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven and eight now we continue with arm
circles yeah remember we lift the arms
both at the same time
we keep the shoulders down and the
elbows straight all the time and when
you open the arms you pass the hands a
little bit behind your back so that you
stretch the chest muscles okay so we do
eight let's go one
two
big and slow
three
four and go straight
five both arms at the same time six
seven
and eight
okay now we do torso bends so we start
by lifting one arm make sure the elbow
is always straight and the hand is
pointing up yeah and then keep the other
hand on your leg and slide it down the
leg until you touch the knee the side of
the knee and hold the stretch on the
side of your torso then use the hand on
top to pull yourself again into the
vertical and we repeat to the other side
okay let's do it four times to each side
alternating sides let's go
one
go down the leg touch the knee and hold
the stretch
and go up
one go down the leg touch the knee hold
the stretch
and walk
two
go down the leg press the knee hold it
up
two
slide down the leg press the knee hold
it
run up
three go down the leg
that's the knee hold it
and up
three
go down the leg
hold it
and up
four
slide on the leg hold the stretch
and up
and four
go down the leg hold it
and up
okay now we open the legs
a bit wider than your shoulders
and we make a circle with the arms and
then we rotate the Torso left and right
until the limit but without twisting the
hip or the hip the hip and the head
always look forward we only move the
Torso together with the arms as one
block and we hold the hands a little bit
below the chest they are not too high
below the chest okay let's do it twice
eight times to each side and one and two
and three and four and five and six and
seven and eight eight more one
to
three
four
five
six
seven
eight ten okay now from this position
put your hands behind your head like
this keep the shoulders down and then
from the profile
you bend the Torso forward until your
back is parallel with the floor and then
you continue going down until your head
is hanging completely yeah and you
bounce three times one two three keep
your knees stretched yeah don't bend the
knees stretched and then from the hair
yeah you move the head up and you go up
from the head it's always better to go
up from the head instead of from the
back because this can be very painful
okay we do it eight times so let's go
one go down
bounce bounce bounce from the hair water
two go down
bounce bounce bounce and what keep the
knees straight
three go down
bounce bounce bounce
and go up
slowly four or down
arms Bounce Bounce from the head go out
five go down
bounce bounce bounce
go up
six go down
bounce bounce bounce go up
seven go down
bounce bounce bounce from the head go up
and the last one eight go down slowly
keep the knee straight bounce bounce
bounce and from the hip go up
okay
now keep the legs open underneath
straight and the heels on the floor okay
grab your hips and move your hip back as
if you wanted to touch the wall with
your bum then move your hip to one side
yeah keeping your knees straight yeah
you will feel a stretch on the inside of
this leg then forward
then to the other side and then back in
a white circle as wide as you can make
it we make it eight times in One
Direction and then eight times in the
other direction okay let's go one
two make a big circle with your hip
three
four Keep Your Head on the same place
five
six
seven
and eight
and nominal Direction one
two
three
four
five
six big circle
seven
and eight
okay now we can close our feet make sure
they are touching each other also the
knees touching each other the legs are
completely closed keep your hands on the
hips if you want and then there is to
bend the knees make sure your hip is
straight bounce three times one two
three then stretch the knees go slightly
forward and then lift the heels as high
as you can and support yourself on the
ball of the foot yeah make sure that
when you're here your knees and feet are
not opening like this keep them closed
okay hold this position and then go down
slowly don't go down fast go down slowly
and controlled okay we do it eight times
let's go one bounce bounce bounce
and up hold it
and down two bounce bounce bounce
go up hold it
and go down three bounce bounce bounce
go down four bounce bounce bounce go up
hold it
go down five bounce bounce bounce
well hold it
go down six bounce bounce bounce
go up hold
down
seven bounce bounce bounce push the
floor go up hold it
and the last one eight one two three and
then go up
hold it
and go down okay and the last one we
stretch the calf myself
so you do a big step back
you find your balance in between both
legs make sure that the heel on the back
leg is touching the floor and then the
foot is pointing forward not to the side
forward because like this you will
stretch the calf muscle properly okay
if you have problems with balance you
can put a few uh your fingers on a wall
or a chair yeah don't lean on the wall
just touch it yeah if you come with one
finger that's okay and then bend the
knee forward until you feel a very good
stretch on the back leg and keep your
your knees straight okay and we hold
this position for 10 seconds for 20
seconds
so one two
three
four
five six
seven
eight nine
ten ten more one
two
three
four
five
six seven
eight
nine
then now stretch the front knee to get
out of the position in a controlled way
and moving to the left side so fit
together and then big step with the
other leg behind
find your balance between both legs yeah
put the heel of the back leg on the
floor stretch the knee and then make
sure that the foot behind you is
pointing forward yeah
bend the front knee until you you feel
the stretch on the calf muscle and let's
hold this for 20 seconds one
two
three
four five
six
seven
eight nine
ten ten more one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
nine and ten and get out of the position
by stretching the front knee okay we are
ready now we can go to the first
exercise okay so for the first exercise
you put your feet together completely
together yeah your knees also as well if
you can and if you use the stick you
grab it white like this and you lift it
above your head yeah make sure that your
elbows are straight not like this but
straight okay this is the starting
position if you don't use a stick then
you can just keep your hands on your
hips like this yeah that's also fine I
like to use the stick because then I
practice balance and posture both at the
same time so it's very effective okay so
in any case this is the starting
position and then I'll show you from the
profile from here you put your weight on
one leg Yeah in this case you start with
the left yeah the left leg the standing
leg is completely straight yeah you
stress the knee then you raise the free
leg like this until your thigh is
parallel with the floor more or less
yeah and then from here you lower the
free leg you extend it behind you until
you touch the floor with your toes then
you find your balance between both legs
yeah in the middle you bend both knees
and then you go down control slowly
until your back knee touches the floor
and then you go up again
and then you go forward and then you
start again yeah you lift your free leg
Yeah so you lift the leg put it back go
down touch the floor go up and lift the
leg that's one repetition okay so let's
do it eight times with each leg yeah
let's start with the left leg as the
standing leg okay
so I'll do it from the profile so that
you can see my free leg uh better yeah
so if you use the stick raise it above
the head make sure your arms are
straight if not just keep the hands on
the hips yeah that's fine then put your
weight on the left
and one raise the leg
touch the floor
go down
and one
two
raise the leg
touch the floor
go down
and go out
three raise the leg
touch the floor
go down
I don't know
or raise the leg
touch the floor
go down
and one
five Raise the leg
touch the floor
go down
and go up
six raise the leg
touch the floor
go down
I don't know what
seven raise the leg
that's the floor
go down
and go up and eight raise the leg
touch the floor
go down
and go up okay good relax the legs and
now we do it to the other side yeah so
feet together
raise the stick above your head if you
use it
and put your weight on the right leg
Yeah make sure your knee is completely
straight and then we start with the left
leg up yeah so let's go eight times
one raise the leg
touch the floor
go down
and go up
one two raise the leg
across the floor
going down
and walk
three raise the leg
touch the floor
go down
Ward
four raise the leg
touch the floor
go down
and go up
five Raise the leg
touch the floor
go down control go up
six raise the leg
back to the floor
go down
and go up
seven raise the leg
touch the floor
go down
go up
and eight raise the leg
touch the floor
go down
and go up okay good relax the legs and
let's go to the next exercise okay the
second exercise is very similar to the
first yeah you also start with your feet
together completely together the knees
as well if you can yeah legs together
straight and if you use a stick you rub
it wide and you put it above your head
making sure that your elbows are
straight yeah if you don't use a stick
then hands on your hips okay and from
here
this is the initial position so you also
put your weight on one leg here on the
left in this case make sure yours your
standing leg is straight then you lift
your free leg until your thighs parallel
with the floor and then you extend it
behind like before but this time don't
touch the floor with the toes yeah keep
the dogs in the air and then from here
you bend the knee on your standing leg
to go down and then you extend any
to what yeah and then you lift your free
leg again and that's the exercise that's
one repetition yeah so in this exercise
the free leg never touches the floor
yeah you lift it and then you extend it
back in the air you go down you go up
you lift it again so it never touches
the floor and another thing you have to
be careful with when you bend the knee
on your standing leg Yeah make sure that
your torso is not going forward don't
don't do this
[Music]
yeah going forward with the Torso make
sure that
your torso is straight when you go up
and down yeah completely straight okay
good so let's do it eight times to one
side
and then eight times to the other side
okay so we're ready fit together
put your weight on
your left leg make sure you're standing
there is straight and then it's going
times one lift
extend
go down
and work
two lift
extend
go down
and walk
three lift
extend
go down
Ward
Four Leaf
extend
go down
angle
five
lift
extend
go down
go up
six
leave
extend
go down
and go up
seven
leave
extend
go down
and go up
and eight lift
extend
go down
and go up
okay
good now this will take turns to your
side
so feet together raise a stick if you
use it
put your weight on the left on the right
leg the right leg
and then let's go eight times lift the
leg leg
extend
or down control
and go out
to lift
extend
go down
and go up keep the Torso straight yeah
three lift
extend
or down
go up
four lift
extend
go down
and go up five
lift
extend
go down
go up
six lift
extend
go down
angle up
seven lift
extend
go down
and go up
and eight lift
extend
go down
and go up
okay good now relax the legs because
this one was tough and let's go to the
next one okay for this exercise you
start with your feet apart yeah same
distance as your shoulders and you're
waiting in the middle yeah in on both
legs yeah if you use a stick same thing
grab it wide and lift it above your head
like this you're making sure your arms
are straight if not then hands on the
hips yeah and now I will show you the
exercise from the front yeah but then we
will be together I will show you from
behind so that we have the same left and
the same right okay but now just watch
how this works so from here the first
thing you do is you shift your weight to
one layer yeah just one leg without your
weight and then you cross the free leg
behind the standing leg Yeah you do like
a lapis
and then you cross behind then you find
your balance between both legs yeah the
weight is on both legs then you go down
yeah by bending both knees until your
back knee touches the floor if you do it
right your back knee should be almost
touching your heel yeah that's the best
position okay so you are here and then
you push the floor
you go up again and then you return to
the center
yeah and then you do the same to the
other side you shift away you make a
circle on the floor you cross the leg
behind you find the balance between both
legs you bend both knees you go down you
touch the floor with a knee the back
knee and then you go up again
and then you return
to the center yeah now something you
have to be careful here with this
exercise is the position of your back
foot when you cross it yeah if it's too
close to the standing leg it will be
very difficult to go down because you
don't have space yeah if it's too far
away it will also be very hard because
your base is too wide so the best
position you find when you make a circle
with a foot like a lot if yeah if you
make a circle around your standing leg
then when you go down your knee should
be behind your heel touching yeah that's
the best position okay then when you go
up yeah don't wobble yeah imagine that
somebody is pulling you up
yeah of course not so fast but imagine
that you are being pulled from up and
that will help you grow up yeah okay so
let's do it eight times to each side
alternating sides yeah left and right
left and right and now I will show you
from behind we will do it together and
I'll show you from behind so
feet apart here weight on the center
straight posture lift the stick above
your head if you use it and then let's
go one
hit the weight
cross behind find the balance
go down
Ward
return to the center one keep the weight
cross behind
go down
and go up
Center two
cross behind
pull it down
go up
Center two comes behind
go down
go up
Center Three cross behind
go down
go up
Center Three cross behind
go down
go up
Center four cross behind
go down and go up
go down
go up
Center four more
five close behind
go down and go up
Center five
cross behind
pull it down
go up
Center Six
cross behind
go down go up
Center Six
cross behind
go down
go up
Center seven cross behind
go down
go up
Center seven
cross behind
go down
go up
Center and eight cross behind
go down
go up
Center an egg cross behind
go down
go up and
Center okay good now relax the legs and
we can go to the last exercise okay the
last exercise looks like the easiest to
do but I find it the hardest yeah it
starts with the feet together again you
have fit completely together mix
together if you can't leg straight and
if you use a stick same story without it
why
and put it above your head making sure
that your elbows are straight okay then
from here you put your weight on one leg
yeah now I show you from the front but
when we do it together I will show you
from the side yeah and then you lift the
foot of the free leg just a little bit
yeah you don't need to lift it a lot
like before just like you are not
touching the floor that's enough and
then the exercise has two parts the
first part is you bend the knee of the
standing leg you go down and then you
stress the knee you go up and the second
part is you go a little bit forward with
your weight and then you lift the heel
of the standing foot and then you lower
the heel okay when you do this movement
yeah when you lift the heel try not to
touch the floor with the free foot yeah
try not to help you that's cheating keep
your free food always away from the
floor yeah and if you need to fight with
your balance try to use your core yeah
keep your core tight and fight for your
balance with the core okay so we will do
it eight times with one leg and eight
times with the other leg okay now I will
show you from the profile and I will put
my standing leg towards you because in
this exercise the three leg is not doing
anything yeah so the standing leg is the
one that you want to watch okay so let's
go put your feet together
if you use a stick put it above your
head put your weight on your left leg
and raise your right foot just a few
centimeters of the floor and let's do it
eight times one
go down
go up
lift
and down two go down
go up
lift
and down three go down
go up
lift and down four or down
lift
and down five go down
go up
lift
and down six foot down
go up
lift
and down seven go down
go up
lift
and down and eight go down
go up
lift
and down okay now relax the legs and
let's do it together certain times yeah
so we're ready feet together lift the
stick if you use it otherwise hands on
your hips that's fine
now put your weight on the right foot
yeah and lift your leg your left foot
just a few centimeters of the floor and
let's go in times
go down
go up
lift
and down
two go down
go up
lift
under three go down
go up
lift
and down four go down
go up
lift
and up five go down
go up
lift and up six go down
lift
and down seven go down
pull up
lift
and down and eight go down
go up
lift
and down okay relax the legs and now a
tip is that this exercise as you can
feel puts a lot of pressure on the calf
muscle yeah the calf muscle is working
over time so I recommend that after you
do this exercise a few times
you stretch the calf again yeah stretch
the calf one more time so that you help
the muscle to recover yeah and another
tip I have for this exercise is that as
you do it several times yeah again and
again and your legs become stronger yeah
especially your calves and your your
ankle this joint yeah
the priority
should not be to lift the hill as high
as you can yeah but to keep the heel off
the floor as long as you can yeah so for
example when you when you do the the
exercise next time yeah
and you leave the heel first maybe you
lift it and you put it down again
immediately yeah up and down up and down
that's okay the next time try to wait
one second up yeah lift wait one second
I'm done the next time you wait two
seconds lift one two and down and so on
yeah every time you do this exercise try
to wait with the heel lifted a bit
longer and a bit longer yeah because
this will help you a lot for example for
long Planet arrows or long endorse
pivots yeah figures where you need to be
on the ball of the foot yeah that's what
you want prioritize being able to be in
that position for a longer time instead
of lifting your heel as high as you can
which is not the priority okay so that
was the routine now I would recommend
you that you do the whole thing at least
twice more okay that was a nice routine
for balance and I hope you liked it and
I would like to say thank you again to
the people who support this channel if
you would like to make a donation so
that I can spend more time making videos
for you or if you would like to book an
online Tango class then the links are
down below in the description below the
video yeah I love to work with people
who watch this Channel and help them
with their Tango yeah so if you are
interested in that then don't hesitate
to contact me okay in the meantime thank
you very much for watching and I will
see you in the next video bye